I'm excited to be talking here at by
data Global and today I'm going to
elaborate on machine learning models
retraining
so just to add to it I worked evidently
where we build machine learning
monitoring tools and we build it open
source so everyone is welcome to join
our GitHub and see what we have for
machine learning model monitoring and
testing and I want to start from the
very basic question why do we actually
retrain machine learning models in the
first place
and well when it comes to serve machine
learning models in production we see
that this model starts to interact with
the real world and this world is never
constant a lot of features can change
their distributions and this makes model
irrelevant so machine learning models
quality starts to degrade
uh luckily while we apply a machine
learning model in production we can
collect some data which is done
basically by a simple login in this new
data we can see a lot of new patterns a
lot of new objects that demonstrate new
behavior for example like in this
example we might work on fraud detection
problem and when new types of Roads
achieve you can just log it then labeled
data and see that well there is
something new and we do retrain in order
to demonstrate our model new data new
types of fraud like here that model can
retrain learn new patterns and increase
quality again so that's the idea and
that sounds very nice because well we
need to keep a high quality
so this is the reason why a lot of
companies who actually
serve machine learning models in
production do retraining and basically
there are two main strategies which you
can observe if you talk to someone who
serves machine learning models in
production so those strategists are very
popular and first is pretty
straightforward
using historical data you can define a
schedule and stick to it for example
decide to retrain your models daily
weekly or monthly this is quite nice
solution because it's very easy and
there is no overthinking you decide once
and you stick to this schedule but there
are some cons
if you decide to retrain your model very
often you might spend a lot of resources
to retraining but if your data doesn't
change that fast then probably you will
you will have very similar models and
just spend those resources to retraining
uh if you do it automatically you will
have more complex architecture of your
services and more expensive support and
sometimes it makes it can make things
even worse
together with this strategy we have an
alternative fund for example Define a
monitoring create some triggers and
retrain models only when something has
changed basically when you get some
alerts
well the process that architecture is
more stable and easier to maintain
because basically all you need to do is
create those awesome triggers and
retrain only when something has happened
the cons are that it's really
um needs to have a strong developer who
understands the a lot of risks and can
Define proper alerts right because if
you don't do that you will miss
something
well it's also required to build the
proper monitoring system which is also
takes some resources but this also can
work well we have to register
straightforward strategies and the
question is
what are any alternatives
so let's see what you also have
um basically I believe it's very
important to mention that when it comes
to retraining it's not it's not just
retraining of the machine learning model
right they also need to generate new
data set which might take quite a lot of
efforts because well we need to run a
lot of pipelines to load data Maybe
process some missing values clean data
calculate features right to draw in a
lot of tables sometimes so we need to
make sure we did it right check its
quality then basically retrain model
which is comparably simple but still you
need to have resources and maybe work on
this data sets maybe drop the oldest
part of data or something like this then
we need to evaluate models quality right
because
um if we want to deploy this model
especially automatically we need to make
sure that we deploy in something which
is at least better than the existing
model and basically we need to
technically switch our service from the
previous model to the new one which
means means to Archive the previous
model then load the new one and update
all the systems that we updated the
model so there is new model ID in logs
and stuff like this so pretty a lot of
things
and it basically means that this
retraining comes with the cost the
benefits from the updates in the model
should match with the resources we spent
and there are quite a lot because we
spent time to retrain the model its
computational resources especially if we
train something pretty heavy like neural
networks deep ones we need to spend
Human Resources if it's critical model
and we need to manually assess the
quality and make sure there are no
biases
and the fat no fairness issues right and
sometimes we need to support pressure
complex service architecture and process
automation if you need to make it quite
often and we prefer to do it
automatically so it's very important to
make sure that the benefits from
retraining really match the cost to
spend to doing that
and actually retraining is not the only
option you have at hands because
basically we can do nothing if there is
no quality job we might go and work with
our data to fix all the data quality or
maybe update some pipelines it might
bring the model's quality back to high
levels you might switch to another
models for example the previous versions
The simpler versions you can switch to
non-motional learning based solution
which actually solves the same problem
we can of course retrain models still or
rebuild it entirely using another
algorithms so now let's discuss how we
can be pragmatic and decide what action
to take depending on these circumstances
this basically means that it makes a lot
of sense to develop a strategy based on
possible actions we just listed them
service properties and many other
conditions like resources you have at
least how many specialists do you have
and how business they are currently the
model criticality right because maybe
that's not very important model and it
makes sense to retrain it more rarely or
maybe it's super critical model right
because the each individual models here
and things like this
and I would like to bring an example
here and show how I can develop such
strategy
based on models quality
so that's how the algorithmite looks
like for example if you're lucky to get
the feedback group pretty fast I mean to
get the feedback very soon like when we
recommended something to users and then
just they or click or view what we
recommended then we have feedback like
straightforwardly and in those cases
where we do not have very long delay we
can base our strategy on model quality
drops so the first question we need to
ask here is did machine learning model
qualities job because if no we can do
nothing and that yes we need to figure
out what has happened and here are some
different options because well the
model's quality might drop because of
data quality issues so this is second
things you need to check and if there is
some issues let's fix the data of course
it's not related to retraining right
because there are no issues let's check
whether the environment has changed for
doing that we can check for data drift
or concept drift
if we see some issues here so let's
think about your training if not then I
suggest to go for technical review
because probably if there is nothing
happens to data pipelines at least you
didn't find anything and there is no
change in the environment but the
quality somehow dropped it looks like a
technical issue maybe you need to dig
deeper find some bugs or maybe
um
find some other processes updates and
accounts with
but let's go back now to the case where
we observed some drift in this case we
might consider retraining or other
systems where we do not need to have
machine learning and maybe can say solve
the same problem using rule-based system
or something like this so uh if
we have enough data to retain which is
very important question here we can just
try your training and if model school is
improved then great let's switch to new
model if not then let's do some model
review maybe you can come up with
another algorithm maybe you can choose
another hyper parameters and still
uh increase the model's quality
if you do not have enough data to
retraining let's check whether I have
alternative systems which not demand
that amount of data for example rule
based or maybe first first principle
models and let's check whether this
model help us to increase the quality
because if yes great then let's switch
to it at least while we are accumulating
more data and if not then let's again do
model review and maybe come up with some
another alternative Solutions so that's
basically how we can come up with the
strategy to update our model razor then
just do retraining by the schedule but
there are still some issues to discuss
because well great algorithm but how to
apply that how to answer to each of
those questions and now I'm going to
elaborate on that and share some
thoughts on how this algorithm this
strategy can be applied in practice
and first question was did the model's
quality drop this is pretty
straightforward especially if you like
it to get the feedback so in this case
you can just monitor for model quality
in this case I suggest only be careful
about the fluctation of model quality
because well we do not need to
alert the quality drop if it's just a
fluctuation and I really suggest to not
just see in the model's quality in time
but also analyze Euro distribution it
will help you to see whether the
distribution is shift or the year is
still symmetric to zero and you'll be
more certain about whether this is the
quality drop or just the foundation
it's even better if you have a dummy
model which you can compare against the
real one and you will see is there a
real quality drop or just some something
that happened occasionally
well if you already know how to detect
quality drop the next question is data
quality right because if there is a drop
in most cases that happens because there
is something with the data right and
here I want to show you the tests which
we haven't evidently uh this helps you
to perform test after each steps of
pipelines because well when we
prepare the data to be applied uh in to
be used in machine learning models
probably we will have like several steps
in our Pipelines what we can do here to
add each step
um each additional step after each step
in our Pipeline and run some tests in
there
so this test will help you to see
whether there are some quality issues
for example you can compare the amount
of rows the amount of columns the mean
values of very important features and
see whether there are some changes or
not for example if you expected to have
like 100 columns after specific step but
suddenly you have only 50 then this is
the data quality issues and checks very
nice here you can use custom checks or
maybe Define your specific ones and see
whether something went wrong
a really big fan of that because I
believe it can cover like most of the
issues
now I know how I can see uh the data
quality issues third question is data
drift because if there is quality drop
but no data issues then probably this is
something with the environment right and
evidently we have probably a lot of
pre-built report which can help you with
that
so anyway it doesn't really matter which
specific tool you use it makes sense to
account for data drift and maybe cancer
drift how you can do that I would
suggest especially if if you talk about
tabular data analyze your very important
features and see whether there are some
changes in distributions for example
here is the preview of the report where
we calculate data drift or just distance
between distributions
for each individual features and there
are information about whether drift was
detected what test or distance we use to
detect drift and the visual
distributions which are very helpful
because well sometimes you have
seasonality right and it isn't the real
drift you just see that well things are
different from work in days to weekends
but if there is the real Drift We need
to intervene and do something so this is
why I suggest to not just limit our
efforts to check in the P value and
distance sometimes it makes sense to
visually observe what has happened
uh our first question was do you have
enough data to retrain and this is very
important if we detected drift and we
see that we actually need our model to
learn some new patterns from fresh data
and this is pretty tough one because
well if you have very complex algorithm
that needs more data to be retrained
right and we wrote a pretty huge blog
about it I'm sharing the link here so if
you're interested I suggest you to go
there but let me now briefly share the
idea
uh if you have quite a lot of historical
data what you can do is to perform some
experiments to see what is the minimal
enough amount of data you need to build
the new model
and historical data you can actually fix
on the desk set then um move back to the
past in terms of historical data fix the
smallest trading set and start training
the model continuously increasing the
size of this trading set for example
starting from one day and adding by
adding data by hours or maybe days to
see what is the minimal amount of time
you need to have to actually retrain
your data to increase on quality and
test for example you might see that if
you collect data for three days that's
enough to return model but maybe you
need to have more data for example data
for seven days or 10 days and this is
pretty different situation because well
if you just detected drift and you do
not collect this data yet probably it's
too early for a training right this is
why I really am I suggest to invest some
efforts into this analysis on top of
historical data there are different
strategies sometimes you need to
combine our older trading set with the
new data sometimes you just want to drop
all the other data and only use the
Freshman this is all questions that you
can answer with help of historical data
so that hesitate to conduct many
experiments because it really saves then
a lot of time in production
so that's how we decide do you have
enough data to even try retain our model
or not
so the alternative are different types
of models that we can apply to solve the
same problem and pretty often we have
some options there at least we often
have the previous models or simpler
versions for example here I mean if you
have pretty deep neural network which
helps you to solve the problem probably
you might build something simpler maybe
linear models uh linear regression I
mean maybe some boosting or baking so
you might have the Alternatives here
together is machine learning based
alternatives
for some domain areas you might have
something else for example first
principle models like thermodynamical
models maybe something related to
physics or chemistry and in this case
you can easily compare the quality of
this non-motional learning model this
machine learning model right and if in
this particular circumstances
non-mission learning based model works
better why not to switch to this model
and this not only works for first
principle models you might have some
heuristics for example recommend
products by popularity and sometimes
especially when they work for these
people with our customers we might
perform some manual processing right so
we might
switch some users to manual review while
we are solving some issues with machine
learning models and there's also a
solution here so it makes a lot of sense
to know what alternatives you have and
sometimes switch to it while we're
solving problems with machine learning
models
so final things I want to tackle here is
does it increase the quality and here I
mean any kind of models or rule-based
systems or heuristics we use to solve
the problem
so a very good strategy here is to
create something which is called Golden
set data set and uh I really mean it
here because that's very important to
invest a lot of time into creating the
goods and golden set
here it makes sense to
make sure that your golden data set
contains all relevant segments cases
objects classes so if you have pricey
different types of objects in your data
set it makes sense to add all the types
of such objects to your golden set to
make sure that your model works
correctly on all of those segments if
you're known if you know that you have
some Corner cases or maybe uh non-obules
scenarios then also add them to your
desk set because you need to make sure
that model works not only on top of
ordinary cases but also on top of this
corner cases so if there are some
representative long-term trends at them
add some data from
um weekends at some data from work in
this maybe from some specific events
it's all should be placed in your golden
test golden set because it will help you
to see what is really happening so this
data set should be curated to reflect
assumptions about the data and as soon
as you go on this data set you might be
more
he might really rely on the results we
will get after you apply your new model
to this golden data sets and see the
results
so uh let me show this strategy again so
we previously discussed how we can
perform all these checks starting from
quality drop and then go into Data
quality issues data shifts do we have
enough data to retrain do you have other
systems and does it actually improve the
quality and the good news is that all
these checks can be automated right so
basically you can write discrete
or create a test which helps you to
perform all of these checks and then
create two actions create actions that
should be triggered after you get the
answer to all of these questions which
is pretty nice and well with this means
that you can be very pragmatic about
whether you're retraining your model now
or maybe doing something else like
nothing sometimes it's also
can work and now I want to sum up what
you just discussed before
and I want to start from sometimes blind
retraining can be okay strategy well if
you have enough resources and you just
return your model every day why not if
you if it doesn't really cause any bad
consequences right if you have enough
resources why not but um it's very
optimal
sometimes you can miss the true quality
Decay uh if you retrain your model not
uh often enough or maybe you can waste
more resources than you really need if
you do a train your model pretty often
so this is why they can come up with the
better strategy of updating models in
production
so how to do better
I believe the best way is come up with
the retraining strategy and then test
the strategy on top of historical data
this will help you this will help you to
see did your does your strategy helps
you to
cover all the known issues because the
historical data allows you to label all
the issues with which has happened
before and you can see whether you use
the training strategy actually helps you
to like trigger your training when it's
really needed or not trigger it when
it's not needed right so you can use
historical data and make in front
choices
then when you satisfied with the quality
of your training strategy you can start
use it in production and still see how
many alerts you get do you miss some
quality drops and then adjust the
strategy maybe add more tests for data
quality issues when you see that you
missed something maybe create more
strict rules
um and to deduct quality drops earlier
maybe if your quality dropped by like
two percent that's already the moment
you want to get the alert maybe you need
to wait to ten percent right so all
these parameters can be adjusted during
the production usage so tune your
training approach and automate it of
course because well the automation
always
helps us to
apply these decisions faster right
without having the humans in the loop
but sometimes it makes sense to
intervene and see what has happened so
this is why let's
keep humans in the loop and at least
rarely update models quality and see
what has happened do some deeper
analysis
so basically that's all I wanted to
share with you today about model
retraining and if you have some
questions I'm happy to discuss them
thank you so much we did have a question
it looks like another
Community member has answered it already
but I let you add something if you want
the question is why not add new data to
the already existing data in the model
and retrain again
just where you detailed the information
of the initial data and gain information
of new data
uh yeah so that's a very good question
and I believe it's one of the possible
strategies so uh if you have historical
data I would rather contain the
experiment and see whether we need to
drop all their data or not because if
something uh if there are some drastic
changes then the older patterns can just
I'll make things worse and in this case
it makes sense to totally remove them
and start collecting the new data but if
there is no drastic changes and all that
is still useful then it's very good idea
to combine combine them maybe perform
some relating like this might as a bit
older data and at higher rates to new
objects and I still have combined data
set so as we always transfer in data
sense right all questions to experiments
yep that's a good answer thank you
um we have four more minutes so let's
take a couple more questions
uh the next question is
would it be feasible to learn that
retraining strategy by using
reinforcement learning
um I think it might I think I'm not
catching it but you may understand what
they're trying to say uh provided that
we know the possible actions retrain do
nothing change version and states
very good question uh I would I would
start from the event today uh never seen
this uh easy this strategy used in
production but um so I will just
elaborate theoretically but I like to
General ideas so um basically uh in a
very changing environment we can do
something like this especially if we
have a lot of historical data where we
can train our risk reinforcement
learning algorithm right so if you can
allocate like data Maybe for
I believe couple of years to observe the
whole seasonality and things like this
probably you can perform
something like that so I would not
suggest to start from that but if you
have pretty well defined strategy it
works and you want to optimize optimize
that and maybe uh train some
reinforcement learning algorithms that
will help you to cover
um many many production models that you
have uh in place then probably it makes
sense to try that and see whether it
works and anyway if you have a lot of
historical data why not to try and see
whether it works better than something
we created manually or not I think it's
very interesting experiment
yeah that's not interesting thanks yeah
I think I also understand it now thanks
for your answer as well
um next uh some just deep asks can you
talk a little bit more about Golden Rule
oh sure that's one of my favorite topics
uh so when it comes to creating golden
set it's a super important to not just
take the most recent data right and say
that now that's our validation data set
I would suggest to uh take the data from
pretty different pretty long historical
period and see what specific objects or
Corner cases we had so for example if we
are talking about the problem statement
when where there are a strong
here seasonality I would at least
suggest to take data from all different
months take data from different week
days
right maybe take something from uh some
weekend celebrations like new year or
Christmas take data from Summer and
stuff like this and the same comes to
different customers if you see the
segments of very heavy customers who
come often at those customer Studio data
set same for new customers who has no
history and probably very low data to
apply model at them as well and this is
how you can think about it so um think
about different potential problems you
can see maybe if you previously did
something like segmentation on top of
your objects derive data from different
segments and that's by doing that try to
create very diverse data set and make
sure that all the interested segments
even if this are a smaller one are
presented in this data set it will help
you to see whether for example you
generally increase the quality of your
model but fail some small but still
important segment this is why I believe
here is very important to cover all the
corner cases and even smaller segments
of objects